[Musique]
instagram de lancer une toute nouvelle
fonctionnalité le carrousel on a
maintenant la possibilité de publier sur
une seule publication des images des
vidéos on peut panacher quelques images
des vidéos le maximum ses 10 et ça c'est
la grande nouveauté du jour enfin grande
nouveauté du jour qui arrivait quelques
jours toujours est il que c'est tout
nouveau
alors je vais expliquer comment ça
marche je vais présenter la
fonctionnalité directement sur mon
téléphone et j'ai expliqué en quoi cette
opé est un super coup marketing
instagram c'est 600 millions
d'utilisateurs actifs par mois
instagram c'est une machine de guerre
c'est la deuxième machine de guerre
facebook juste après facebook facebook
instagram whatsapp et justement je te
parle de votre simple le jour en me
disant qu'effectivement il avait créé
les statuts les statuts qui copient
clairement les stories snapshot
en ce moment il faut le savoir facebook
et sur une vraie offensive par rapport à
ce match at love shack qu'ils ont voulu
racheter il ya quelques années
l'athlète a refusé donc en ce moment
marc zuckerberg et toute son équipe sont
un petit peu en guerre parce qu'il faut
savoir que snapshot va entrer en bourse
au printemps prochain
donc facebook et son équipe fait tout
pour ralentir la croissance de ce chat
pour que snapshot est une rente
rembourser soit moins percutante s'y
perdre des utilisateurs s'ils perdent de
la valeur
ils perdront l'argent et tout ça ça fera
les affaires de facebook instagram sait
mais instagram
ce n'est pas que instagram c'est aussi
doux brengues hyper valls layout les
stories est maintenant carrousel donc en
réalité instagram c'est un ensemble de
fonctionnalités
instagram est hyper diversifié propose
plein de fonctionnalités qui sont toutes
top et on va aller voir directement la
toute nouvelle fonctionnalité tu vas
sortons d'instagram directement je vais
cliquer pour ajouter une photo op
on va commencer par faire des photos
tiens me voilà salut premières photos
bîmes
très bien deuxième photo bîmes troisième
photo bîmes encore une photo on fait
plein de photos et justement maintenant
ce que tu vas faire c'est que tu vas
dans ta bibliothèque et tu vas cliqué
tout en bas à droite tout en bas tout en
bas tout en bas à droite tu as la petite
icône où il ya plusieurs boutons tu
clique dessus
hop là dessus tu vois c'est la haine se
mettre en surimpression et tu clique
donc à une en bas à gauche 2 3 4 5 6 7
tu fais suivant tu les as tout dans
l'ordre dans lequel tu as cliquez
ensuite choisi le filtre le fils qui va
s'appliquer sur tout un bon on s'en fout
en ce matin de juno voilà ça nous fait
une belle tête de vainqueur
tu peux choisir d'appliquer un filtre
différent si tu veux sur les photos tu
cliques sur ta photo ça te louvre et hop
on va se mettre jean sérien maintien
voilà en noir et blanc terminé et si tu
veux commencer avec celle là tu laisses
appuyer dessus tu te mets dessus tu
laisses appuyé et tu peux la décaler tu
as vu l'icône qu'est apparue en aussi la
petite poubelle tu peux la supprimer tu
fais ce que tu veux une fois que tu as
mis tes photos dans l'ordre que tu veux
maximum 10 photos tu peut panacher
photos et vidéos les deux marches
une fois qu'ils adorent lors que tu veux
tu fais comme avant suivant tu publies
ton texte new carrousel avec deux aces
avec deux r est un seul ace new
carrousel on va se mettre un hashtag
carrousel on envoie je publie et sa part
directement c'est parti maintenant que
tu es sur ton d'instagram tu le vois
comme plutôt classique sauf que en
réalité si tu regardes sous ta photo il
ya plusieurs petits points qui
permettent de savoir que c'est un
carrousel et si je décale j'ai toutes
mes photos sur une seule et même
publication tout simplement
c'est extrêmement simple par contre il
faut savoir que les laïcs que tu vas
avoir directement dessus
ce sera des like uniquement pour la
publication donc pour le carrousel il
peut pas y avoir d light pour les photos
individuellement
de la même manière pour les commentaires
quand j'arrive directement sur ma page
instagram
tu vois que en haut à droit
des photos où il ya un carrousel tu as
des petits carrés sur celle d'à côté
j'avais fait aussi ses des photos prises
cet hiver et tu te retrouves phoques les
petits carrés voilà c'est toujours le
même délire au final l'objectif
d'instagram par rapport à ça c'est quoi
alors c'est déjà par rapport aux
utilisateurs d'offrir effectivement un
nouveau service pour être toujours plus
complet et pour je dirais embêter les
autres pour embêter les concurrents est
le concurrent principal c'est qui c'est
nachat jetant appareil tout à l'heure ça
permet à ses utilisateurs de partager
plus de photos et du coup de les garder
plus longtemps dans l'application
quand tu vas arriver sur ton carrousel
qui va faire défiler plusieurs photos du
coup tu regarderas encore plus de
contenu et il y aura plus d'interactions
plus de curiosité on aura toujours envie
d'en voir plus ça nourrit effectivement
l'expérience utilisateur et ça permet
d'avoir une rétention qui beaucoup plus
grande et de garder encore plus
longtemps les gens directement dans la
dans l'application instagram ce que dit
instagram se permet aux personnes de
publier plus de contenus plus de photos
sur un seul événement avant était à une
super soirée qui sortait en gros la
photo de l'événement la plus belle photo
par les deux plus belles photos tulle et
n'était directement photos instagram
maintenant ce que tu l'as pouvoir faire
tout pouvoir publier des photos vidéos
par rapport à un seul et même événement
dont s'épargner vraiment d'avoir quelque
chose de plus complet et d'avoir un
contenu qui est encore plus riches pour
un événement pour des vacances pour une
recette de cuisine pour un tuto tu peux
vraiment l'utiliser pour énormément de
choses
cette nouvelle fonctionnalité carrousel
tu le retrouves dans la version 10
points 9
enfin du moins à partir de la version
10.2 d'instagram donc si tu n'as pas à
10.9 tu ne le verra pas tout de suite
mais avant toute chose cette opé c'est
un véritable coup marketing
il faut savoir que les carrousels son
arrivée il ya quelques mois déjà pour
les annonceurs
c'est parce qu'il a déjà vu mais tu as
des publicités où tu peux faire
effectivement défiler les photos des
annonceurs instagram a donc pris ce
système là pour l'appliquer au grand
public
à la seule différence que les annonceurs
ne peuvent pas choisir l'ordre de leurs
photos les photos sont calculés
automatiquement par un algorithme
d'instagram effet là où c'est hyper
intelligent c'est à dire que instagram
pour les annonceurs va publier
photo la plus performante celle sur
lequel il aura la plus grosse
transformation le plus grand engagement
le plus grand nombre de like de
commentaires et d'interaction et de
cliquer le but c'est quoi c'est
d'augmenter les revenus publicitaires
c'est une sorte d' abbey test si tu veux
je sais pas si ce mot là tu parles dans
le jargon marketing lab étaient sales
permet de tester différentes
possibilités et de mettre en avant
celles qui marchent le mieux donc pour
les annonceurs c'est un outil marketing
extraordinaire pour le grand public
aussi parce que ça permet de garder les
gens l'otan dans l'application d'offrir
plus de contenu en un minimum d espaces
et ça permet troisièmement de faire une
unique incroyable hasna chat et
maintenant qu'est ce qui va se passer
cette semaine on a eu droit à what's up
statut là on a droit au carrousel
d'instagram pour le grand public
et maintenant snap chatte par entrer en
bourse au printemps prochain
facebook a largement le temps de faire
d'autres offensives et de chercher
vraiment récupérer du marché et est
numéro nachat au maximum qu'est ce qui
va se passer
qui va gagner la guerre est-ce que cela
tchad la pouvoir rentrer en bourse en
attendre plus en plus affaibli face à
une concurrence qui monte énormément ça
c'est des questions intéressantes
on va continuer à regarder parce qu'à
mon avis va y avoir encore beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de choses à dire
dessus tu te rends compte qu'en peu de
temps on a eu instagram stories whatsapp
statut instagram carrousel aux halles
elle ce qu'est ce qu'on va avoir
parce que si on regarde le plus près ce
que propose de carousel d'instagram on
est sensiblement notre corps trouve au
niveau des stories c'est-à-dire un
contenu qu'on peut faire défiler photo
après photo pour ensuite passer à autre
chose
c'est vraiment très très intéressant
donc c'est passionnant on va continuer à
regarder ça de plus près dis moi toi ce
que tu en penses
est ce que tu trouves le carrousel
intéressant est ce que tu penses que tu
l'a publié plein de photos ce que tu es
frustré par fait de voir m une seule
photo à chaque fois et est ce que cette
fonctionnalité de tente énormément
dis moi ce que t'en penses tu mets tout
en commentaire mais moi aussi nom de ton
compte instagram que j'allais faire un
tour moi c'est monsieur underscore grrrr
on reste connectés mais moi tout en
commentaire
regarde cette vidéo pense à ta bonnet et
puisse te dis à très bientôt